thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a bone
crushing wild ride with Stevo man this
episode is nuts I address the situation
with the comment I left on Bam's
Instagram then deleted then it became a
global news story man this situation is
nuts and I'm here on Australia where
there is definitely a criminal element
plus I've got a special guest at the end
of this episode maybe halfway through
who's broken more bones
than maybe anybody I mean dude the guy
absolutely cannot count how many bones
he's broken I mean it's in the hundreds
it's insane and uh wow what an
incredible ride stick around for this
special guest and Brace yourselves for
the wildest of rides let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen the Wild
Ride podcast with me
Scott Randolph and a special surprise
coming up
so we've done a podcast with no guest
once before it would have been great had
we not gotten dinged with an age
restriction for me having a a a
profanity filled rant turns out you can
only say the f word so many times in the
space of like 15 seconds or something
like that yeah and when I when I was
going off about the death penalty I
managed to say the f word like seven
times in 15 seconds at least I very in
case we're at it again and we're in
Australia are you gonna talk about that
ah the band because that's gonna be a
little bit longer maybe like the BAM
situation I wrote it down to talk about
um
I posted this
this comment on Bam's
Instagram
because I was just like
like I had just had him on tour with me
for for 10 days we did nine shows
together
he he was really pretty great the whole
time he's funny he's fun he was a he was
a good guest right and
the the last the whole time he was
telling me like dude will you reach out
to to Nikki his his wife his baby mama
we reach out to Nikki and see if we if I
can spend the day with Phoenix you know
I want to see Phoenix because where our
last show of that run happened to be
Santa Rosa California which is super
close to where Nikki was
and and his son was so like that that
was it was like this whole leg of the
tour 10 days nine shows just culminated
it was just a big journey to his son and
sure enough on that last day bam was
reunited with his son you know uh we all
spent the day together it was a great
day we did the the last show that night
and it was a big deal because bam had
been practicing
um you know opening the show with me and
working up to going out on stage by
himself and he did that he went upstairs
it was like kind of triumphant not only
did he go out on the stage by himself
but he brought his five-year-old boy
with him on stage and it was just this
like heartwarming wonderful thing and
then at you know at the show kind of
Backstage
after the show
um it was determined that bam was like
okay bam you're doing great like his his
uh baby mama Nikki says like you know
what like let's like uh let's give this
a shot we'll spend another day or two
you can spend another day or two with
your son and she's like yes awesome
Bam's gonna be reunited with his son and
then for him to go and like leave the
the the theater that night and like
it's come like four five six in the
morning he's posting like hateful stuff
about Knoxville and Tremaine like it's
it's like really dude like you know what
that means every time he's posting like
resentful stuff about Knoxville and
Tremaine it's a terrible sign
he admitted that it was because he was
drunk and it's like dude come on man
like I was just so
bombed you know I was you know I was
equally disappointed as I was
unsurprised because that's the nature of
the the disease you know but like I was
just so struggling with that and so I
went and and it also kind of felt like I
beared some responsibility for his
hateful post about Knoxville and
Tremaine because it was like it was sort
of like that happened under my watch you
know like oh you're gonna cart bam
around on tour and like you're okay with
this and like not that I didn't care
that much but you weren't even with them
you were he was a friend yeah I wasn't
it was as soon as I wasn't with them
that that's what happened yeah and uh
and so it was just bugging me man it was
bugging me all day and uh his his
hateful post had been up for 22 hours
and I was just like ah you know I was
just like so I couldn't write this
comment on there like you know it's
saying like largely what I just said now
but uh and I wrote it and I was like
dude you're dying bro like you're dying
and it just sucks because like I you
know I want to like save you but I can't
do that you know like I can't make you
want to get better like like uh I can't
do the work for you you know and so I
write this whole comment and I just
posted it and then I showed it to Lux
and luck says that's not a public thing
you should and I'm like yeah you're
right should I delete it
that comment had been up for literally
two minutes two minutes and the post
that I commented on had been up for 22
hours it wasn't like brand new in
everybody's feed plus it was on bams
like secondary Instagram the one that's
actually him which has a way smaller
audience not Captain Captain
was the one that I posted on two minutes
and I took it down and then the next day
TMZ reaches out hey is this real like
dude that thing went [__] viral and
then it's on like yeah dude page six TMZ
Yahoo news like it like I I really
didn't
care for that to be the case it wasn't
my goal to to make all that happen yeah
once the wheels are in motion you're
like [__] it yeah but that's it means
how I feel you know it's how I feel and
and I didn't want this podcast to be
about that you know like but uh but
they're like um yeah I was just curious
about that yeah I I wrote it down as
something to talk about and now uh have
you talked to him I you know I I had
some text with them I said you know bam
we've got those boards and and we could
still sell a ton of them but uh what I'd
really like to do is open up a trust for
your son and have money go into a trust
and that got no response there's no
response there
um of course since then like you know
the news was on TMZ that that Nikki has
filed for legal separation and spousal
support
um
so I I'm feeling kind of inclined to uh
how help everybody involved by uh you
know moving forward with those boards I
think that it'll be good for his son
it'll be good for his baby mama it'll be
good for him and um I'm not in any quick
and I'm not in any rush to do it but um
I think that that's something that would
that we should
probably go ahead and do yeah all right
it was nice having them on tour though
when he was epic when he was good I
loved it I remember we went to the Nike
store and uh in Portland and I was like
oh dude you ever like uh ride for Nike
he's like yeah it was the first
skateboarder to ever ride for Nike I
mean just the stories that he had going
through Portland was I mean he's
what a lot of people don't know about
him is like dude he's a great [__] uh
driver to like uh be in charge of the
music there's always good music going on
he's kind of like a a teenager in a fact
where he's like he's he's always trying
to make jokes and do funny impressions
like he did he's different than what I
always thought he was he he's playful
he's playful he's playing full and uh
dude I love him man he's he's a brother
you know and it's crazy how like that
whole lawsuit situation with him suing
jackass
and every you know
it's like it really really put a a
strain you know like his whole
relationship to jackass with the the
director Jeff Tremaine has a restraining
order against him so they cannot have
contact like legally how long do
restraining orders last forever forever
yeah I have no idea but but from what I
understand it's still in place and you
just can't sue somebody and then turn
around and be Bros with them yeah you
know but like I'm in this position where
I'm uh like
I'm uh
Switzerland you know I'm the one guy who
has been cool with bam all along you
know and even though I've never
sugarcoated anything you know and and
whether I'm okay with bam still kind of
remains to be seen yeah you have a weird
relationship with band where you can be
harsh to him and he just listens to you
yeah
anyway I I think that I do still that we
are still all good
um
moving on I didn't I just wanted to say
some positive things about bam because
he really it was he's fun and he's funny
and he's [__] he's great to hang
around plus dude that kind of stuff you
know even having put on like a
substantial amount of weight like
ripping I thought man I thought like at
this point man I think I can take him I
cannot outskate bam well yeah Burnside
yeah yeah it's funny than that that
fight at Burnside you saw the fight I
was not there for that you weren't there
for that I went to Burnside the next day
yeah I don't even want to because like
it was just a trip that like these two
guys got an argument one guy pulled out
mace and then they grabbed the mace from
this guy and mace the guy who pulled it
out his face and then they pepper
sprayed him with his own pepper spray
and I wanted it as they beat him up yeah
well and I was like man dude like this
would be great to have on film and then
you look around and nobody's filming and
I'm like I'm not gonna be the [__]
[__] to film and then the cops came
and but anyway it was just a good
experience all around in in the Pacific
Northwest was bam right bam we miss you
come back
I love bam
and uh and you got a video coming out
yeah we're we're working on a video
well that got pretty heavy which makes
me extra grateful that this episode is
brought to you by better help better
help is a service which matches people
up with professional licensed therapists
and I think that's very important
because speaking up about what's going
on is the way to stay healthy I do it I
feel good about it and better help has
matched up like three million people
with professional therapists plus they
make it so easy you don't have to go to
some office in person it can all happen
online you can do it by video chat
they've got just so many people that
they can help and by plugging in what it
is you want to work on you get matched
up with somebody who's ideal for you and
it's already super affordable but if you
go to Better Health
help.com slash Stevo that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Devo you get 10 off
your first month so you really can't go
wrong and again you do better work when
you're in better shape mentally
spiritually physically better help is
the ticket so go to betterhelp.com
Stevo and figure out how much therapy
can help you thank you better help now
let's get back to it
thing about Australia is that it they're
very very touchy about
um letting criminals in which is so
ironic because the whole reason that the
that they speak English here is because
it was a penal colony
like that's how I started England yeah
England would stand all of their their
gnarliest criminals like that that was
what a life sentence meant at some point
in England maybe in like the what 1700s
or something like uh the life sentence
was just being banned from England going
to Australia a life sentence man you got
thrown on a on a ship and shipped off to
Australia forever
that that's what a life sentence was
what is that I have no idea
is that you
yeah well way to go Kook okay there's a
nice Opus carry on
so anyway so yeah it's ironic that there
they started out as a bunch of criminals
and and they're really really strict
with their immigration their customs and
uh it's an ordeal I was like biting my
nails about whether they were gonna let
me I'm always biting my nails about
whether I'm allowed into Australia and
our our new regular
third mic co-host Vinnie skinny Vinny
did not make the cut too much of a
criminal yeah whatever what's his felony
again like a drug dealer like moving
weight hardcore like heroin like drug
dealer yeah
but like we wrote uh there's maybe like
10 to 12 character reference letters
right I mean he's been sober for five
sober for five years he's uh doesn't
live in a porta potty anymore yeah
and you got sweated though because they
let you in the last time and then the
only charge that you had was trespassing
for the Sea World stunt right but it was
a hold up like it was touch and go you
didn't know until Monday that you were
leaving on Thursday you know it was it's
bizarre and um
like every time you apply for a Visa
you're dealing with uh like a different
individual and it's up to like the
Customs officer that just gets the yeah
so like I was allowed in last time but
maybe I'd get a different customers when
you landed did you get a customs person
or did you guys go right when I landed I
got a shirt and the oh you go this way
oh really you're gonna deal with the
Shakedown did they talk to you and and
they're like good and I said hey you
know like does it help that I've got
um my Visa is granted and I'm like
holding up my thing and they said yeah
that gets you up to a good start oh [__]
what's what's the hardest country you've
ever had to go into Canada it would be
Canada if I didn't have a Canadian
passport
you get sweated in England
well I have an English passport too
[Laughter]
um England's pretty easy like they I've
never heard of people having a lot of
trouble getting into England
but uh yeah so we made it out here and
we're a man short because of the yeah
the strict policies
the tour is a hit
um and I want to make this podcast epic
and then like we did with the last time
we had no guest we
um
gave away free stuff the yeah the
[__] shoot you still have the shoes
the black and yellows oh yeah that's
right you got to give them away on this
one because for what happened was nobody
came it was creative to get a hold of me
and actually Steve okay I filmed the
Green Screen Video this is what happened
like you said like somebody get a hold
of me in a creative way which turned out
to be an epic fail like because all that
did
was Knoxville's sexiness like dude did
you know this guy we got everybody who
is associated with us inundated with
Annoying messages from tons of people
because you were you were saying you're
gonna give away this pair of special
Nike Air Jordans and uh and that was
just awful so I I said what would I do
to
that are you know be creative to win
this and I thought hmm
I could do like set up like a green
screen and make it so like I climb out
of the shoe and become a giant and reach
down and pick up the shoe and say thanks
Scott Randolph
and I didn't even have the shoes I just
took a Google image of them and and made
that happen yeah you did a whole video I
mean you spent a couple hours I got it I
used the first take I did it like it was
actually pretty easy and quick all right
so you're in possession of them what are
you gonna do with them now I won the
shoes and they're leather yeah I don't
want to wear leather shoes so um if you
want to get there what are they called
again I think just the the Nike black
and yellows okay Nike black and yellows
yeah I'm not I don't wear leather so if
anybody wants these Nike Air Jordan
black nails do not reach out to anybody
I know and annoy them with messages but
do something creative tagging me like I
always look at everything I'm tagged in
on Instagram because at the end of every
one of my shows I invite the whole
audience to pull out their cell phones
and and take a photo and I say if you
guys want to post this photo now
um I will like every single one of them
I see and I religiously do that every
night after the shows I call it doing my
homework I go through my my uh feed of
photos that I'm tagged in everything I'm
tagged in I look at it and I like
everything that uh people take you know
post from the show
um so I see everything
tag me in some creative way to win these
shoes
um and we're gonna give away some other
stuff too
man I thought that it was going to be
more popular when uh when I got my new
car and I was like okay I'm gonna live
in this I'm gonna live in my car for a
week and then I was like well that's
kind of boring how do I make it more
exciting and I decided to sleep
overnight in my car while hanging over
100 feet in the air from a crane on the
UFC headquarters property
thought that would be like wildly
popular and it just didn't hit as a big
thing
when we had like a Haggard little
welding team like on the spot like put
together a thing I was
good for my life
yeah I don't even know why you did it
yeah and it wasn't that big of a deal I
was like I made it into an initiative to
try to raise money for people who don't
have a choice but to live in their car
by uh you know fundraising for Habitat
for Humanity of Las Vegas I took a
thousand prints of this epic photo of me
Standing On Top of the roof of the car
while hanging over 100 feet in the air
signed a thousand prints and I said uh
whatever I'm gonna you know 25 bucks for
the autographed print and 100 of the
proceeds will go to Habitat for Humanity
of Las Vegas and we sold like half of
them even that wasn't a big hit now I
promised that 100 of the proceeds for
this uh signed print will go to charity
so
that that ship has sailed now that these
photos are are not allowed to generate
any profit because of that promise I
made so we have only two choices throw
them away or give them away let's give
them away so we're gonna give them away
if you want an autographed
copy of a photo I I hand signed every
one of them I spent half my life signing
stuff and um this uh this hanging from
the crane standing on the car it's gonna
be zero dollars from the the moment you
know all you gotta pay is for shipping
and it'll be like maybe if you're in the
states like five bucks for shipping
seven or eight seven or eight all right
um let's uh and then we'll put that in
the number one position on stevo.com
yeah correct okay yeah
um all right I've got some other stuff I
wanted to
um address like my my diet god dude like
I I'm kind of OCD with uh like the
people taking pictures at the end of the
show that's why I like normally like
I'll stand on top of a stool so that I
know if I see any photos of me on stage
where I'm not standing on a stool then
that meant that person was
using their phone taking photos when
they're not allowed to I always have
some kind of thing to and so now lately
I've not been standing on the stool I've
just been taking off my shirt so that I
know if I see photos of me on stage and
I have my shirt on that that's not an
approved photo like I'm psycho like that
but the problem is when I take off my
shirt I'm straight fat these days like
uh it's not a person does it bother you
because you do it every show it bothers
the hell out of me I wouldn't be [__]
caught dead with my shirt off dude and
like dude I'm so embarrassed of how much
weight I've gained but like uh but you
did like you're you don't like it but
you still have no problem taking your
shirt off
I have a big problem with it
I'm liking all the photos like I'm
horrified I'm more horrified than the
last every time you just look at your
stomach in every photo this is terrible
so I'm back to this like program of
taking a photo of every single thing I
eat and sending it to a mentor in in the
food program because I like it consist
of
I I just avoid flour and sugar
so no bread no like anything with sugar
you can have sugar in it obviously but
if sugar is like a main thing if it's
like considered a sweet can you have
sugar
but uh yes sir so and it's crazy like my
yo-yo diet like I'll go
like I'm gonna I'm gonna look great I'm
gonna get ready I'm gonna look great
um so now before our special surprise
how about that the mod sun
do you think the podcast broke them up
for those of you who don't know last
week's episode was with Mod Sun who's
all in the news this week because Avril
Lavigne broke off their engagement now I
don't know what was going on in their
relationship but I do know what is going
on in my relationship and it involves
activities which are enhanced by
bluetooth tablets okay now Bluetooth
tablets are
delicious for one they've it's like a
new flavor I noticed when I take them
they're even more delicious these days
and they've got the same active
ingredient as both Viagra and Cialis but
they cost only a fraction of the price
now here's the really good part which is
that if you go to bluetooth.com and use
the promo code Stevo you can get an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets and all you have to pay is five
bucks for shipping yeah the Bluetooth
tablets an entire month's Supply are
totally free if you use the promo code
Stevo bluetooth.com another great thing
about this is that you can take care of
your prescription right online with the
medical providers that they have at
bluetooth.com very quick very easy no
trip to the doctor nothing just handle
it online super fast you got a whole
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets on
the way to you for free all you got to
pay is five bucks for shipping so one
more time go to bluetooth.com and use
the promo code Stevo now let's get back
to it
she's like oh do you had threesomes
before us
I'm sure that wasn't it yeah but dude it
was really weird man well I didn't even
read the article the article said that
she was getting very comfortable with
Tyga
um that uh that that according to her
Avril Lavigne her relationship with Mod
Sun had been on and off for a number of
months hmm and um
the uh what else
um comfortable with Tyga
they remember they swear up and down
that uh that there's nothing
um romantic there but whatever in any
case I mean dude like that the mod Suns
rep came out and said uh you know if if
anything to three days ago they were
engaged and together and if anything's
changed since then it's news to mod Sun
wow and I love that guy man I really I I
enjoyed that guy dude I would hate to be
a celebrity and then like all of a
sudden like you read an article you're
like geez I guess my girlfriend broke up
with me you know what I mean it's like
you find out about [__] on the news and
and how much of that is like actually
real I mean have you ever read stuff
about yourself that's not real
yeah like there was that
there was some like tablets for a long
long time ago about how I got like a
spotted smoking pot with Brad Pitt I
thought there's no truth to that one
there's no photos or anything it's just
a yeah it's just like and um I was
loving that one and then there's another
one way long ago that uh Lindsay Lohan
asked me to lend money that I I that uh
that Lindsay Lohan borrowed money from
me and I lent it to her there's no truth
to that but I kind of loved that one too
let me ask you something real quick on a
side note do do you let people borrow
money from you or do you like nah you
know I mean if if uh
if somebody's gonna borrow money from
you you you have to
uh give it away just give it to him yeah
because I A buddy of mine borrowed money
for me and then uh a couple weeks ago
and then he he hit me back I was like oh
he's gonna pay me back and he asked me
for like triple the amount more and I
was like
you just can't expect yeah like by
definition if someone's borrowing money
from you you can't give it to them
without expectations without expecting
that you'll never get it back and
because that's the case you should just
give it to him okay cool
all right so now uh we're gonna
introduce
our uh our our new buddy Latham
all right
laid them Latham there he is dude let me
give you mine make sure you talk close
yeah be careful buddy is that no good
yeah I think that's all good yeah sweet
okay Latham is my my new buddy who we
met through what's called Steve a raw
it's a a special fan subscription page
that that I have for showing wildly uh
explicit stuff
um
what it really has turned into is just
more of an intimate Community how about
the discussion forum now everybody it's
so good it's like everyone can just post
their own ideas and then you can see
what people are thinking and yeah like
every member of my community can make
their own posts so I just put up um
doing like cartwheels off of a right
thing that was cool like that was cool
like I mean dude that was super brutal
imagine if you did that
yeah can we talk about your story can we
talk about why you're in a wheelchair
what
I was born with a brittle bone Condition
it's called osteogenesis imperfecta
and there's seven different types of
osteogenesis imperfecta when I was born
there was only four but now there's
seven so type one is sort of like your
average Joe just accept a bit smaller
and they they are a bit brittle but they
can walk and they lead mostly normal
wives they are just a little bit fragile
then you have type twos which sadly they
die at Birth
they don't usually live like if they do
make it out of birth it's usually only a
year and then there's me I'm the type
three
which
sort of is like this most severe one
that you can have that you live through
right okay type two is the worst but you
don't live through that yeah but type
three is like I'm the most fragile of
all of the osteogenesis people I've got
like the stunted growth I'm like really
short
uh so you were so you break bones super
easily easy dude like coughing sneezing
like you were born with broken bones yes
I was born with a broken collarbone and
two broken legs
and in your life you're 23 years old
how it's not even that accurate to say
how many bones you've broken because
you've broken so many of them multiple
times yeah it's more accurate to say how
many times you have broken bones
it has to be in the hundreds it has to
be like you feel it when you break it
like so here's the crazy thing right so
I get like Sensations right like I can
feel when my arm starts to go weak and
I'm like okay my arm's gonna break in
the next few days and then I'll feel it
just go bang doing nothing doing nothing
I could just move my arm the wrong way
and it was just I I ever broken your arm
jacking off actually no that's the one
thing I've never broken my arm doing
I've broken my arm trying to open a
bottle of Coke but I've never broken it
from jacking off now wow that was a
really slick way of saying are you able
to jack off
no [__] problems there
great
and you've got this wonderful smile
like when you laugh and you smile the
first thing I noticed when we met on a
zoom call a good sad it's it's it's
really special man thanks dude and uh
and and you being such a fan and paying
such close attention to everything that
I do like you know I love that I'm such
an attention [__]
it's epic Okay so
you live in
Rockhampton Queensland yes Australia
where we're doing the show tonight yep
and and you've not seen The Bucket List
show no I've never seen it heard a lot
about it yeah many of the stunts that
are on there and I'm so excited to see
it it's it's a great show it's a really
great show
um so you're gonna see the show tonight
we're thrilled about that we're gonna
roll out the red carpet for you
I'm gonna give you a tattoo today oh I
did not tell you um shout out to Dean
Rankin by the way he used to work on The
Simpsons he's actually the guy that Drew
it up for us
wow so that's really authentic that
tattoo wow okay good enough I told you
that now like I mean it's clearly
simpson's-esque but but I'm glad to know
that
um
as with Simpson's characters uh it's
called colored in yellow yeah like do we
want to really color it yellow probably
yeah well yeah because I would say it's
mostly Simpson death so yeah because I
got a few fingers as well so be like are
you worried about breaking any bones
getting a tattoo I've got one dude don't
even [__] no I've got one tattoo oh
okay okay what are you doing with your
arm you you tell us that you broke your
your arm yeah and you took off the cast
yourself prematurely yes
um and so the bread never fuse it's just
floating yeah essentially yeah my bone
is like still in two pieces like should
I do the thing yeah if you can do it
without hurting yourself
[Laughter]
[Music]
we should have had you sign some kind of
a waiver
oh Jesus okay
[Laughter]
all right please no more
please no more is that something that
you found yourself saying about a bad
habit that you have if so I think it's
time to try fume fume is a device which
you put flavored cores into it these
cores are powered by plants and when you
breed these flavors it's not only not
bad for you I think it's actually good
for you and I'm I'm crazy about the mint
flavor and I'm super upset that in one
of these hotels in Australia I left my
fume device in the room and I I don't
even have a habit that I'm trying to
break I mean I I've been pretty uh
pretty free and clear of my uh physical
vices for almost 15 years I still love
my theme device I'm gonna tell Lux when
she flies out to join me in Australia to
bring me a backup theme device because I
love it that much and it really can help
you quit some of these bad habits that
you might have so
I want you to try this go to
tryfume.com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use the promo code
Stevo to get 10 off the journey pack now
the journey pack has the latest most
awesome theme device in three different
flavored cores again I love the mint and
by doing that you get 10 off so go to
trifum.com and use the promo code Stevo
for 10 off and good luck knocking off
those bad habits now let's get back to
it
okay is that why you got the tattoo
there because it's already broken
no I just happened to be convenient spot
yeah really like where are you getting
this tattoo uh I want to get it just
like on my leg really because I wanted
to choose like a spot that's easy but
like see to have like a solid canvas on
my arm it was really hot because my
arm's like weirdly shaped so how do I
keep grabbing the skin and like
scratching it out so there to me you
think there's a possibility that it you
could break your tip or fib
no no I'm just curious and how fragile
you are oh dude like
I don't think it will it just depends on
how much pressure he puts on he's a he's
a heavy-hander I don't I don't know like
I'm pretty terrified but uh
you you talk me through it it'll be all
right and it's a challenging tattoo it's
gonna take some time but uh but yeah
like for you man I'm I'm stoked I'm
super stoked
um now
you were telling us that you've just
recently learned that there is some way
that you would be able to drive a car
yes well
a few years ago I had an initial driving
assessment test by an occupational
therapist they're like a specialist that
will see if you can drive a car with the
right modifications and it turns out
that I was able to drive but back then I
didn't really I didn't really
wasn't really that Keen on it like
really
um I didn't have much Independence like
I used to weigh a lot more than what I
did now like I've lost 15 kilos in the
last probably like a year wow cool yeah
I'll show you photos after this like it
was way different and um so I've just
I've gotten a lot of Independence and
that's the one thing that I'm mainly
striving for is independence and so now
since I figured that out that I can go
for the driving I can um
sorry I'm just like lost the words I did
it's all good my man
um how did you lose weight
I don't even know dude to be honest like
I just started dropping weight loss I
feel like my metabolism just
was reversed like when I was younger it
was really slow and then as I've gotten
older it's just sped up okay because I
don't eat anything different the only
thing I stopped doing was snacking at
night time well there you go
because I went to a dietitian and she
was like she was like oh the one thing
that you can do is stop snacking at
night time I said well done like I could
do that easy yeah that's your answer
that reminds me of the the joke about
the guy who uh he goes to the doctor
says Doctor my uh my penis is turned
orange and I'm just freaking out and and
the doctor says oh well uh you know like
let's run some tests and he runs the
test he comes back says there's a really
new tester completely normal I can't
understand why your penis is turned
orange this is what what uh you know
maybe this is like work related stress
what do you you know do for work it's
just doctor I don't even have a job like
I don't have any work related strips all
like he says what do you do all day long
this is why I'm just sitting around
watching porno and eating Cheetos
yeah
that's your situation pretty much yeah
yeah you can't figure out how I lost
weight I just stopped bingeting in the
middle of the night chocolate oh yeah
well that joke pretty much it like I
just stopped eating like because I still
like crap well I don't I'm not exactly a
healthy guy but I just stopped eating
after eight o'clock at night like once
eight o'clock it's like that's me done
yeah yeah don't eat anything at all even
if I'm sitting there starving I just
right don't eat anything yeah okay so
now we're striving for more Independence
you're you're uh
you're now very interested in driving
yes and
what kind of a car are you allowed to
drive all right so what I have been told
from an occupational therapist is that
because I do have limited Mobility like
I can't get up and walk you know like I
do I'm stuck to this chair like to get
around I'm stuck in this chair so I have
to get a car that's big enough so that
way my chair can drive into it
and into the action driver's seat and
get locked in there so I think she said
it was a sprinter van okay that's cool I
think it's sort of like you know like
the big bands you see around like yeah
sort of thing yeah it's kind of like the
podcast man yeah yeah kind of like that
yeah but um yeah so that's what that's
what she said that I needed and um I've
been looking around a little bit it's
actually really hard just to find
like people to help me do this like
OTS are so scarce around Queensland
OT occupational therapist like because
the lady I spoke to was actually located
in New South Wales and I'm in Queensland
and so she could help me as much as she
could but
she couldn't actually
help me help me like she couldn't come
and give me the assessment because I
need another assessment now because it
was a few years ago when I had the first
one I couldn't exactly move much back
then like now I can get myself into my
bed out of my bed like a move around all
myself like change my own clothes go to
the toilet myself pretty much like
except for number twos but you know
other than that I can pretty much do
everything myself and I just want to
make that my next goal is getting that
car to have that next little bit of
Independence so the so provider that you
can purchase the vehicle which sounds
like it's the Sprinter van type thing
yeah if you can purchase that and you
own it then the government yes will make
the modifications for you yes the
national the national in this National
disability insurance scheme such a
mouthful they will cover all of the um
modifications to the car that I need
necessary okay which is great news and
that that includes like hand controls
like they just said able the pedals they
put everything at the hands like there's
stuff like you can use your head to use
the blinkers like if you need to like if
you went into like all this detail with
me there's so much technology that you
can use that's cool cars these days it's
just like that's abdominal and the the
the problem is that that the the
Sprinter van the in Australian dollars
is like a minimum of seventy to eighty
thousand dollars
yeah like it's very very costly and I'm
on the Disability Pension which is like
your guys um Social Security yeah Social
Security it's like Centrelink is what we
call it here and yeah yeah so you've got
a GoFundMe yes to help you
um you help me raise money for this car
so I hopefully I can well not hopefully
that way I can get the modifications and
that way I can drive where's it how do
they get to the GoFundMe
um the go find me is that my Instagram
at just some guy in a chair ah man how
do I not already follow you on Instagram
okay just some kind of chair just felt
like that yeah that's a great that's a
great handle exactly it's just some guy
in a chair
[Laughter]
okay just some guy in a chair and uh to
make it even easier in the in the the
description the link for your GoFundMe
is in the description it's in the
description of my profile you said that
you've been able to raise a little bit
of money so far like a little bit not
not like a lot by any means like just
over 500 okay just over 500 okay yeah
it's not a lot but yeah it's something
okay slowly we'll get there I uh would
like to get there quickly and and I
would like to make a donation myself I'd
like to get on that GoFundMe and and uh
really push it along are you serious man
yeah for sure man like uh I I I've got
you brother
um I'm not gonna give you the whole 70
or 80 000 but uh I'll give you a good
chunk of it dude and uh I will beg the
listeners of the Wild Ride podcast to uh
to join me in doing that
I know what that means but I like
all right
it means so much dude like I'm trying
not to crawl right now God don't don't
try too hard
yeah oh yeah don't yeah don't do that
don't break down like dude that means so
much to me man like even you see having
me on the podcast itself just to tell my
story is just a lot like
I can't even put it in words what it
means to me man I'm gonna be forever
grateful to you bro like well I did I uh
I meant I couldn't candidly the I've
never heard of this condition where you
break bones hundreds of times uh many
many times I've never heard of that I
think uh you know as heartbreaking as it
is it's also like just fascinating you
know like it's a fascinating story and
you're just a lovable dude and uh it's
an honor to have you on the podcast
thanks man I really appreciate it yeah
um it's it's an honor and and uh and and
it's it's some bravery to get on here
and speak up about it yo because like
there has been actual two other famous
people with my condition their names
were Sean Stevenson and Quentin kenehan
but they have both tragically passed
away
I don't know like right I don't know
actual the life expectancy of my
condition but what I've learned so far
because I went to a convention when I
was about nine and I met no old people
with my condition like done the oldest I
met was like 38 and these other two guys
they died at like
mid 40s 40 like so to me I've already
lived like half my life dude
if that's like you know because I didn't
meet anyone over like 40 years old at
that convention with my condition so
it's like it says on the internet that
my life expectancy is normal but are
they talking about type lines
like they don't get into into specifics
and so another thing I really want to do
in my lifetime is try and start some
sort of research into my condition
because I feel like there's not enough
like how rare is your condition
I don't know the numbers to be exact but
I've only met outside of like
conventions and stuff
I think one other person with my
disability my friend has met one other
person as well so two other people that
live in this town what kind of
conventions do you go to
[__] conventions
but like what do you mean we're
conventions like enough convention is
the right word but I haven't been since
I was a kid but like it just like they'd
invite like all these like people with
like disabilities okay but it was mainly
like osteogenesis which is my disability
which is mainly like an oi convention is
what they call them we all went into
Sydney and we all like
gotten his big ass hole together and we
all just started talking about what life
was like and I was really young so I
didn't really take all that much in but
I remember a good deal of it like enough
to know that how many people were in the
group in the convention oh that was that
was a fair few there man that was
probably at least 100 or two like
probably everyone from Australia like to
have that condition was probably there
like
it was there was a fair few people I
also went to a um wheelchair camp
really yeah that was funny man what's a
wheelchair Camp it's a camp of a
woodchamp people
what do you guys do there all day well
around
no but um like I don't know it's like
I've never been to a normal Camp so I
couldn't really like distinguish it from
a normal cam but like we just did like
activities and stuff yeah tried to bond
in that like but it was just a load of
[__] man okay any any girls with your
condition that are cute they keep in
touch with that like everyone with my
congestion kind of looks the same so she
looks like my sister so no really well
I'm not like my sister but she would
look like my sister if we were together
yeah so no girlfriend oh no no I'm a
virgin dude are you yeah man
GoFundMe for getting them laid
I mean is it like would it be rude to
suggest that maybe we could like at
least try to get latham's wiener sucks
hey like if you just want to guide for
that man God damn that right I'm fine
with that
yeah
I mean I don't know imagine the title of
the podcast trying to get disabled guy
lagged
I remember uh
there was a show I that I did many years
ago called Dr Stevo before I got sober I
only told a little bit of that not much
it was like when I was a lot younger
yeah and and what it was was I was
de-wissifying America one wussy at a
time and and uh like people would send
in submissions that they needed help
from Dr Stevo with some situation and
one guy was like Dr Stevo I've never uh
Kissed a Girl and like you know and I
was and I was like dude we're getting
this guy's wiener sucked and like we'd
straight up did and when the network
found out that we actually videotaped a
guy getting his wiener shot
they were uh is they were very upset
with the situation they buried the
footage and and I was outraged so I went
on my MySpace at the time and had
announced to the world that I did in
fact get a guy's wiener sucked and that
I was getting no credit for it
is prostitution legal in Australia
um I don't know about legal but it's
definitely a thing no money exchange
chance I just got this guy's weight oh
really yeah it was I didn't if I don't
think that that counts as prostitution
if the woman wasn't paid yeah you're
right yeah
all right well we'll work on that and we
can update the uh the audience
I mean it would be uh it'd be pretty rad
yeah
dad I love you so much hey Jeremy what
how long have have we been going here
51 minutes cool do you have anything
else on your uh let me check Ryan
uh
I'm not that mad at hotels anymore yeah
I don't why were you mad at hotels to
begin with I am like uh
very ritualistic like maybe not OCD but
kind of I just have this whole routine
like it's an ordeal for me to move into
a hotel room and then pack up and move
out but
now what I've done
is really pared down my uh
overnight bag you know because I'm set
up on the bus
but I've got this little paired down
overnight bag to just go for a little
jaunts to hotels and the the paired down
version makes it a less of an ordeal to
to
get in and out of a hotel room yeah when
I get into a hotel room I just
shower and go to bed you like lay out
things you [__] do different like you
make it harder on yourself than it
actually is
right yeah I mean I make a lot of things
harder than they actually are Scott
that's that's just me that's how I am
eating soup of the fork yeah all right
well with that said I think uh we will
head on over to the tattoo parlor to
give you your dope ass Stevo tattoo
um
we're gonna recreate your tattoo with me
riding that board being towed by you
sweet man I'm Keen for that and then
that board is gonna be your board oh
really yeah I can ride it too
you do whatever you want with that board
and then uh
yeah and then I'm gonna get like uh get
on your GoFundMe I'll throw out their
ten thousand views thank you Australia
dollars on you thank you so much and
hopefully uh hopefully we get you there
man I hope we can too because like
honestly like
when you asked me to be on your podcast
it's like
I just sort of thought well
this is sort of like my chance to
actually kind of try and make that
happen like that's why straight away
when I asked you downstairs if we could
do it it was like well
I'm never gonna have this much of an
Outreach ever again like ever
like this is the biggest thing I'm ever
gonna do right here you know what I mean
like this is it and you know how anyway
like this is it you never know man
someone might fall in love with you the
way I have and uh have more
opportunities for you yeah we get pretty
[__] rad dude
sorry you Latham
um just some guy in a chair all right
man Everybody follow Latham just some
guy in a chair I just want to say thank
you to Steve again and everyone that's
ever supported me like everyone at my
wrestling wrestling Allegiance
Rockhampton like all you guys you're a
wrestler oh I'm a restaurant training to
be a manager to a wrestling like yeah
the guy that stands on the outside and
like helps him I'm trained to be that
guy
because it stands on the outside and
helps them like you know like
Undertaker Undertaker doesn't really
watch wrestling but uh yeah just a guy
that's like his spokesperson like
unwrestling and [__] yeah like
essentially if someone that I like
manage can't really talk I would do all
the Talking for them I will get them
over with the crowd you know what I mean
right so yeah I just want to take all
the time to just say thank you to
everyone there like they've all been a
massive help to me like I was struggling
a lot last year with like mental health
and stuff and once I joined up with
wrestling it was like
nearly all them problems just went away
man like cool you know it's so good
there and like Robert Milly ways Cafe
Bar he's out he's our sponsor he's been
so helpful to me too very cool time to
suss them out while you're here they're
so good
yeah like all right that's it man thank
you very much for having me Steve and uh
everybody grab those uh
0.0 yeah
get them while they last yeah and
whenever there's a No guest podcast you
know we're giving [__] away yeah dude
thank you everybody yeah
man how rad is Latham and uh his tattoo
came out killer you can see it on
stevoraw.com
um now what else dude I uh
I've talked about the the books
conversations with God a lot on this
podcast how they fundamentally changed
my view of the universe and
life everything and um next week's
episode
is called Stevo's life coach my life
coach being Neil Donald Walsh the author
of the conversations with God book
series
it's a big deal it's a big deal and I I
have been kind of scared about the idea
of putting out that episode because I
wonder like Neil Donald you know like do
people so I'm urging you guys make sure
that you tune in for the Stevo's life
coach episode next week it's really
really special and thank you for
sticking around to the end I love you
guys
yeah I did I'm gonna sleep for the first
time in like two [__] days
laughs